le ciel les couleurs de l'Ukraine comme
un signe de joie pour ses soldats
Ukrainiens engagés dans la bataille de
barmut
il s'accorde quelques instants pour
partager le pain de Pâques les combats
font rage à proximité
bien sûr j'aimerais être à la maison
c'est beaucoup plus amusant là-bas
c'est jusqu'à ce moment précis de
l'histoire de notre pays nous devons
être là pour Pâques
cette année encore des dizaines de
milliers de soldatsukrainiens ont passé
la pack orthodoxe loin de leur famille
asloviancek ces soldats sont bénis alors
que les sirènes d'alerte aériennes
retentissent dans cette région des
bastilles chacun s'est habitué à la
guerre
hier pendant la prière il y a eu un
bombardement près d'ici j'ai fait tomber
une bougie je l'ai ramassé et j'ai
continué à prier si cela s'était produit
l'an dernier nous serions cachés dans
les sous-sols
pour prier pour la paix
nous voulons que la paix arrive le plus
vite possible que tout le monde revienne
vivant et en bonne santé et pour
l'intégrité de l'Ukraine et son
indépendance une fête célébrée également
côté russe avec ses gâteaux
traditionnels préparés pour les soldats
engagés sur le front et des messes dans
les territoires
occupés comme Mario Paul
nous nous réjouissons nous nous
réjouissons d'avoir de l'espoir la chose
la plus importante est que nous ayons de
l'espoir et l'espoir n'aura jamais honte
jamais honte encore et encore je vous
félicite tous frères et sœurs
durant le weekend pascal les combats se
sont poursuivis dimanche Moscou affirme
avoir gagné du terrain à Barmont